va bene buonasera allora io sono colui
che vi separa dalla pausa caffè allora
noi stiamo vivendo un momento storico
molto interessante alcuni ancora sono
bizzarramente convinti che si tratti di
una crisi economica quelli più
lungimiranti hanno capito che non è in
realtà una crisi economica ma è una un
cambiamento di paradigmi stanno
cambiando le regole del gioco proprio
voi immaginate per un attimo di avere
vissuto durante la rivoluzione
industriale ea un certo punto facevate i
contadini un certo punto è arrivato una
tecnologia da qualche parte che ha
permesso di costruire una roba che si
chiamava fabbriche questa cosa qui
questa tecnologia ha avuto un impatto
sia sul cambiamento dell'economia ma
anche sulla società molti contadini sono
sono stati dalle città alle scusate
delle campagne alle città è stato un
cambiamento di regole è un cambiamento
di modelli e noi stiamo vivendo un
periodo molto simile sempre alla base di
tutto c'è la disponibilità di nuove
tecnologie ci permettono di fare cose
che prima non potevamo fare e queste
sono driver spingono i cambiamenti
abbiamo difficoltà a capire o a
immaginare quale può essere il futuro
non siamo degli indovini però quello che
possiamo fare è pensare di immaginare un
futuro partendo da alcuni segnali che
dal futuro ci arrivano che in realtà poi
sono già presenti e poi durante la mia
presentazione che fatto tutta in lettere
perché sono un giornalista e quindi mi
esprimo meglio così che non con le
immagini arriveremo a
raccontarmi anche che già qualcuno sta
implementando questo tipo dei modelli
questi segnali che arrivano dal dal
futuro ci dicono alcune cose molto
interessanti
qui appunto partiamo con queste che ho
chiamato keywords abbiamo appunto il
cambiamento di paradigma che è la giusta
interpretazione invece della crisi
economica ma abbiamo due parole molto
importante lì decentralizzazione e
crescita esponenziale decentralizzazione
è una parola chiara perché poi vedremo
e quella che ci permette di capire uno
dei pilastri di questo cambiamento
paradigmatico la crescita esponenziale e
un altro elemento importante noi
dobbiamo tenere in considerazione che la
disponibilità di tecnologie e
l'evoluzione delle stesse non evolve con
un processo lineare ma evolve con un
processo con una rapidità esponenziale
quindi la velocità con la quale questo
tipo di tecnologie diventa disponibile
in crescendo ogni tanto quando vado a
fare qualche lezione in qualche di ceo
in qualche università faccio questo
esempio
immaginate che oggi sia il 2008 e quindi
pochi anni fa non molti anni fa e io
dicessi una frase del tipo scaricato un
app sul mio smartphone android
probabilmente mi prendereste per
visionario perché ne smartphone android
ne up erano presenti all'epoca oggi una
roba comune per cui immaginate solo
questo in soli pochi anni quanto è
cambiato la nostra percezione altri
segnali che ci arrivano dal futuro sono
il superamento della dicotomia tra
profit e no profit noi siamo abituati a
pensare alle organizzazioni che fanno
profitto come organizzazioni cattive o
comunque non buone in tutto ciò che
fanno e invece siamo abituati a pensare
che per fare cose buone ne dobbiamo
applicare il concetto del no profit in
realtà questo è un processo che si va a
che va a essere superato esiste anche
una nuova forma di impresa che si chiama
benefit corporation
l'italia è il secondo paese al mondo ad
avere una
così una normativa apposita che è stata
approvata lo scorso dicembre le benefit
corporation che possono essere aziende
di ogni tipo e di ogni settore di ogni
dimensione fanno hanno nel loro dna nel
loro processo sia la capacità di
generare profitti valore economico
creare posti di lavoro sia quella
divenne un impatto sociale ambientale
positivo il neo nomadismo o un nomadismo
digitale un altro fenomeno a un altro
segnale che ci arriva dal futuro e che
ci dice che è sempre più persone in
questo pianeta hanno capito che ci si
può liberare della connessione tra il
lavoro che si fa il luogo dove si vive
ovvero uno può fare il lavoro che non
era questo vale per alcuni mestieri non
per tutti ancora naturalmente però c'è
una buona fetta di popolazione che ha
capito che il suo lavoro non deve
necessariamente essere legato al
territorio per cui si muove e va in giro
per il mondo vive un po qua e un po là e
questi sono i cosiddetti nomadi digitali
in quanto digitale è la infrastruttura
che gli consente questo altra parola
chiave blog 5 sono altra parola chiave
molto interessante molto importante
quasi come la parola internet perché
blog chain e una tecnologia uno strato
una filosofia tecnologica quasi che
consente di implementare il concetto di
decentralizzazione poi vivi vi spiego
come qui e poi ho citato altri due punti
che sono la presenza delle città stato
che sempre di più le città
per importanza sostituiranno il valore
dei governi nazionali
la cultura imprenditoriale di nuova
generazione quella delle start up a è un
altro elemento importante perché è una
cultura che è nuova rispetto al modo in
cui si faceva impresa precedentemente ed
è soprattutto globale tutto ciò si
scontra con un sistema che è attualmente
inefficiente le attuali democrazie di
tipo rappresentativo quelle maggiormente
diffuse al mondo oggi stanno dimostrando
non essere più sistemi efficaci per che
concentrano il potere perché consentono
alla strato di rappresentatività di
prendere decisioni non sempre condivise
perché rischiano di essere forieri di
corruzione gli sprechi e del
mantenimento dei delle rendite di
posizione
gli stati nazione dicevo prima sono
sempre più deboli nella loro importanza
nell'equilibrio socio economico che si
sta si sta creando altri sistemi
centralizzati che oggi funzionano con
modelli centralizzati sono come per
esempio quello la distribuzione
dell'energia elettrica energia elettrica
viene distribuita ci sono dalle centrali
da qualche parte che producono l'energia
che poi nelle nostre case uffici
fabbriche scuole arriva con delle reti
di trasporto sistema assolutamente
inefficiente dispersivo altamente
costoso
oggi le grandi aziende che fanno energia
che stanno implementando stanno portando
nel genere te in quelle parti del mondo
dove ancora non è arrivata non lo fanno
così come da noi ma lo fanno con
tecnologie che consentono di produrre
energia nello stesso posto viene
consumata sistema decentralizzato
l'altro esempio è quello del bitcoin i
bitcoin sono molto importanti perché
sono la dimostrazione pratica del
concetto di block chain di cui vi dicevo
prima il bitcoin qualcuno e voi ne ha
sentito parlare sicuramente sono la
prima cripta moneta che sono innovativi
non solo perché sono digitali o perché
sono sovranazionale ma sono innovativi
perché non c'è la banca centrale dei bit
cola
quindi noi abbiamo una valuta che viene
trasmessa su internet quindi mantiene la
proprietà e che non è gestita da un
sistema centrale
questi modelli la della democrazia
diretta cioè la eliminazione dello
strato intermedio tra i cittadini e le e
l'entità che poi gestisce
amministrativamente la cosa pubblica è
già una realtà per esempio nei cantoni
svizzeri lo la krazia che è il sistema
non solo decentralizzato ma anche non
gerarchico è già una realtà applicata da
alcune organizzazioni da alcune imprese
per esempio usano il sistema lo cratico
imprese come medium che è questo nuovo
sistema cioè nuova anche abbastanza noto
e diffuso che molti usano per pubblicare
contenuti su internet lo è la società
che si chiama automatiche che fa che
quella che fa wordpress che molti usano
per fare siti web la palarchi ha invece
è una possibile evoluzione sulla quale
si sta ragionando che è molto legato al
concetto neo normalissimo digitale che è
quella che dice se noi scolleghiamo al
lavoro dal territorio possiamo
scollegare anche i sistemi legislativi e
metterli in competizione tra loro e sta
già succedendo bit nation è
un'organizzazione che sta definendo
modelli organizzativi degli stati
secondo concerto della boxe chain
tutte queste cose sono liberamente
consultabili su internet
eterea un ma è una start up che sta
sviluppando un sistema per la gestione
su basata sulla boxe in dei contratti
degli smart contract quindi anche chi fa
l'avvocato quindi anche un mestiere che
noi siamo abituati a considerare solido
consolidato sarà oggetto di questo forte
mutamento te le porte nomad list sono
due siti che aiutano coloro che vogliono
fare il nomade a scegliere il posto
migliore dove andare di vivere sulla
base delle caratteristiche economiche
sociali di preferenze climatiche o
quant'altro il governo dell'estonia
paese dell'unione europea che usa l'euro
non stiamo parlando di un altro pianeta
ha già da qualche mese reso disponibile
la residenza elettronica badate bene sto
parlando di residenza non di
cittadinanza perché le tasse le
continuate a pagare qui chiunque di noi
virtualmente può diventare può diventare
un residente virtuale l'estonia senza
esserci mai stati fisicamente io
scommetto che molti di voi non sanno
neanche con la capitale dell'estonia
però potete diventare estoni dal punto
di vista in residenza perché è
importante avere questo tipo di
residenza elettronica perché se tu sei
un nome digitali timori spesso quindi
non hai una residenza fisica stabile
però quando devi aprire un conto in
banca deve aprire una società o devi
firmare un contratto ti serve avere
questa residenza il governo estone vi dà
questa possibilità indipendentemente
dato che sia puoi andare sul sito rai
paghi 50 euro una volta loro ti mandano
una smart card con quella fai tutto
altri esempi interessanti sono le medium
automatiche zappos li abbiamo già citati
però per esempio sui generis è
un'organizzazione di un gruppo di
imprenditori canadesi che sta cercando
di sviluppare un modello loro lo
chiamano appunto stampa ap cities dove
l'organizzazione di questi territori è
fatta in un modo in cui l'economia
deriva dal sostenere lo sviluppo di
imprese innovative che nel nell'ambito
dei dei numeri possibili diventano delle
imprese potenzialmente imprese fanno
molti soldi per cui lasciano poi sul
territorio dei dei ritorni economici i
cittadini di queste di queste start up
cities non pagano le tasse ma lavorano
cioè danno un contributo volontario
affinché il sistema funziona questi
signori stanno lavorando per stringere
accordi con alcuni paesi europei
affinché venga dato loro un territorio
un pezzetto del territorio per poter
implementare questo tipo di cose
cito inoltre questo modello cento
inoltre la competizione cioè i
sistemisti gli ecosistemi start up si
stanno sviluppando di tutto il mondo li
cito perché perché è un esempio molto
interessante per capire come se voi
prendete andate sul web cercato una
qualsiasi ricerca che mette a confronto
questi sistemi
scoprirete che il confronto viene fatto
sulla base dei sistemi urbani cioè
quindi non c'è confronto tra
l'ecosistema delle startup in italia in
francia eccetera ma c'è soprattutto
quello tra londra parigi berlino
stoccolma lisbona a milano silicon
valley
ok quindi anche in questo caso stiamo
vedendo come un segnale ci arriva di
questo tipo dove i sistemi organizzativi
urbani stanno acquisendo sempre più
sempre più potere rispetto ai sistemi di
organizzazione che noi conosciamo con il
nome di stato nazione
queste sono informazioni che sono in
continua evoluzione
sono un modo per cercare di comprendere
come è possibile che sarà il futuro ed è
un modo che chiunque di noi che voglia
fare l'imprenditore il viaggiatore
agricoltore l'avvocato il giornalista
deve sapere deve quantomeno tenere
presente perché accade sta accadendo
stanno già arrivando queste cose non
possiamo non esserne almeno consapevoli
e quindi questo è un po il messaggio che
voglio dare
tenete d'occhio questo tipo di
evoluzione io quando ho iniziato a fare
la carriera del giornalista
l'internet stava muovendo i primi passi
e quindi sono i giornalisti che
iniziavano il mestiere per a crescere
più rapidamente alla loro reputazione
cercavano di andare a lavorare per
giornali molto ben conosciuti quindi
associare la propria firma al nome del
giornale noto oggi accade esattamente il
contrario
i coloro che si lanciano nella
professione giornalistica
internet costruiscono prima la loro
reputazione
usando internet quindi associando il
livello di reputazione al proprio nome e
poi sono i grandi giornali che vanno a
caccia di questi giornalisti sul web
quindi stanno cambiando proprio tutti i
sistemi e tutte le regole e il mio
messaggio è non distraetevi perché sennò
sarete così colpiti da questa ondata che
sta arrivando prepotentemente grazie a
tutti buon caffè